[Musica]
buonasera a tutti mi chiamo yuri e oggi
voglio raccontarvi la mia storia
questa storia parte in mezzo a un bosco
sulle colline fiorentine dove ho vissuto
fino a qualche anno fa in questo bosco
tutto era fantastico mi ricordo che
quando ero piccolo alle elementari
uscivo di casa con il mio zainetto colmo
di libri e andavo in mezzo al bosco a
cercare casa ed i calciatori
arrampicarmi sugli alberi più alti e li
stavo a leggere tutto il pomeriggio poi
tornavo a casa e mi infilavo in un
pollaio a cercare uova fresche delle
delle nostre galline cercavo sempre di
mangiarne qualcuna anche se in famiglia
comunque non volevano perché si sa luogo
fresco crudo fa male tornando poi a casa
e immaginavo giochi fantastici con tutto
quello che avevo a disposizione
non sono il tipo da parco sabato c'è il
sabato e comunque domenica sull'altalena
sono il tipo da ero il tipo da
immaginare immaginavo tutto questo è
stato fantastico
era bello anche era fantastico alzarmi
presto la mattina a leggere mi ricordo
che comunque leggevo tanto prima della
giornata alle elementari e le stavo in
questo mondo fantastico tutto il giorno
questo però crescendo mi ha posto di
fronte a un problema il problema della
scelta che è un problema comune cosa
scegliere fra l'altalena al parco e la
casa sull'albero cosa scegliere tra il
pallone da calcio al parchetto con gli
amici
e l'uovo di gallina fresco la scelta è
un problema siamo condannati a scegliere
ogni secondo in questo momento tutti
possiamo fare qualsiasi scelta vogliamo
si può alzare e ad uscire da questa
falla dall'uscita laggiù vuoi lanciare
un urlo fortissimo possiamo fare quello
che vogliamo quindi come fare la scelta
giusta tra infinite scelta
come scegliere con metodo il problema
della scelta ha continuato andare avanti
nella mia vita no si è proposto in
germania dove sono stato per un anno a
tubinga ho vissuto lì in quel periodo
leggevo molto nice il filosofo tedesco
niscemi ha aiutato lui mi ha aiutato a
capire
piano piano come scegliere con metodo
ora facciamo un gioco
immaginatevi il tempo disegnate il tempo
della vostra mente voglio un disegno del
tempo ci siamo macinato credo che la
maggior parte di voi se sia immaginata
il tempo come fosse una linea retta come
questa dove è passato per esempio il
futuro non coincidono mai
sono lì da soli in solitaria ora finisce
nel 1881 si trovava silvaplana in
svizzera e ogni giorno faceva le stesse
cose
ogni giorno si alzava la mattina presto
lista meriggio camminava e pensava la
sera scriveva ogni giorno le stesse cose
fino a che un giorno
provo gioia dolore messe insieme e disse
il tempo è un cerchio il tempo non è una
linea retta ma è un cerchio dove passato
presente futuro coincidono qui in uno
stesso momento
immaginate ora se le scelte che avete
fatto nella vostra vita dovessero
ripetersi in eterno non so cosa provate
no aver fatto le scelte giuste
bene il tempo diventa quindi un problema
morale
le scelte che facciamo qui ora nella
nostra contingenza saremo costretti a
ripeterle in eterno in eterno questa
visione mi ha aiutato molto perché ho
detto se così stanno le cose
dobbiamo avere un progetto
dobbiamo avere un progetto con un
progetto
riusciremo a scegliere con metodo
riusciamo a fare le scelte giuste no
sono quindi è tornato in italia carico
di questa mia nuova filosofia e ho
avviato la mia prima start up e non è
andata molto bene nel percorso per ho
conosciuto il mio attuale socio niccolò
che è un designer oltre un designer
nicolò è anche una persona con un
progetto i nostri progetti erano molto
simili
da lì abbiamo quindi iniziato a
progettare insieme ed è nato slam slam è
il mio attuale studio di marketing e
comunicazione slam disegna è uno studio
di design progettare dall'inglese ogni
cosa per noi era diventato un progetto
ogni scelta
volevamo essere felici di rifarla altre
cento volte abbiamo quindi mi ricorda
all'inizio non avevamo soldi e non
avevamo clienti ma avevamo tempo
all'inizio abbiamo detto di no a un buon
60 per cento di clienti nonostante
ancora eravamo star tacciono perché
volevamo avere più tempo per progettare
ci serviva tempo
questo ha portato a conoscere un un
concorso internazionale di design
il tema era creare un'etichetta di vino
questo concorso qui è un concorso
interessante perché tra i giudici
c'erano alcuni fra i migliori designer
al mondo
quindi era la scelta avrei fatto altre
10 mila volte
e tra l'altro avevo tempo per fare un
bel progetto
abbiamo quindi iniziato a progettare
diviso il tutto in tre fasi analisi idea
forma un buon progetto funziona se
dividiamo tutto in alcune fasi da alcuni
step la prima fase l'analisi dovevamo
creare un'etichetta per la nuova
edizione speciale della marrone
valpolicella un vino che pensa frutti
conosciate
il pubblico era un pubblico alto
spendente questo vino veniva venduto nei
ristoranti quindi non nei centri
commerciali e abbiamo ipotizzato che
fosse sempre un sommelier a raccontare
il vino
avevamo un tema ulisse spesso per un
creativo avere un tema è una cosa
confortante perché ci fa creare
all'interno di una stessa di una sfera
di una bolla quindi il tema era questo
abbiamo iniziato quindi mi ricordo a a
riempire il nostro piccolo studio di 15
metri quadri di allora di immagini pieno
di immagini ma veramente abbiamo
stampato tutte le immagini di ulisse
dell odissea e le abbiamo
incollate dappertutto per terra sul
soffitto in questo periodo anche il 40
per cento di clienti che erano rimasti e
scappavano via a gambe levate nello
strazio queste sono dei fori non c'è e
viene bene con queste immagini
abbiamo iniziato a guardarle osservarle
e abbiamo iniziato a levare piano piano
o in immagine
abbiamo sotto lo scudo abbiamo tolto
piano piano togliendo le immagini è
rimasto il viaggio
eravamo vicini all'idea ma non era
questo il viaggio è qualcosa che si fa
quando siamo pieni di vita ma ciò che si
impara da un viaggio e dopo da qui è
nata l'idea
fase 2 togliamo il viaggio e lasciamo
l'esperienza
abbiamo quindi deciso di illustrare a
livello visivo l'esperienza di ulisse in
un vino
dovevamo dare una forma a tutto questo
che può sembrare banale ma
bene la forma è questa abbiamo scelto
una carta cangiante di questo colore
bronzeo che dice che ricorda sia lo
scudo di ulisse sia la terra madre itaca
ma dovevamo illustrare l'esperienza bene
l'esperienza sta dietro al vino piacere
la bottiglia dietro abbiamo illustrato
l'esperienza vedete dal buio
dell'oscurità attraverso la luce fino a
itaca
abbiamo diviso il vino in 12 tappe a
seconda del viaggio di ulisse che
succede che l'assaggiatore prova
l'esperienza di liszt perché vede il di
non scendere ma non solo perché ogni
tappa è alta
a seconda del tempo in cui ulisse è
stato lì
immaginatevi la scena arriva al
sommelier spiega almeno dice fai
l'esperienza di ulisse giovane coppia
assaggia il vino e piano piano però fa
l'esperienza del viaggio un sorso più
lungo e faida chips uno più corto
eccetera eccetera fino ai fucka fino a
casa è un vino molto pesante 17 gradi
quindi si può creare veramente
un'esperienza a quel punto bene questo
vino ha vinto il primo premio
siamo arrivati primi tra 800 aziende al
mondo i più grandi designer mondo
avevano scelto il nostro progetto siamo
stati esposti al vinitaly da qui da
quest'anno abbiamo vinto altri nove
premi internazionali
sempre sul design
i nove tra i premi più ambiti sul design
nel mondo e abbiamo iniziato a viaggiare
abbiamo iniziato a viaggiare sono state
in cina siamo stati e stati uniti e poco
tempo fa sono tornato in germania dove
tutto è iniziato sla ma oggi è uno
studio di comunicazione design un po più
grandi rispetto all'inizio diciamo che
adesso è impossibile riempirlo di
immagini
e adesso vivo facendo quello che mi
piace fare uso la fantasia ciò che prima
era la mia arma la mia no adesso la mia
arma vivo usando la fantasia e ghiaccio
ciò che mi è sempre piaciuto fare perché
quel viaggio in germania mi ha aperto a
molte cose come concludo concludo come
ho iniziato con la fantasia
immaginate progettate ok progettate chi
vorreste essere con chi vorreste essere
cosa vorreste fare innamoratevi del doss
del vostro progetto dovete innamorarvi
del vostro progetto perché sono sicuro
che se siete innamorati riusciti a
sicuramente a fare la scelta giusta tra
infinite grazie